Наприкінці 1970-х років
тут почали будувати рисову систему.
Рисова система — це каскад таких поживних,
скидних каналів та тих, які подають [воду].
Приблизно 1969 року було закінчено будівництво,
і відтоді тут, у нашому районі вирощують рис.
Площа нашого господарства — приблизно 4 500 гектарів.
Наразі засіяно в нас 1 600 гектарів під рис.
2004 року ми прийшли на місце збанкрутілого радгоспу,
і з того часу [працюємо].
У нашому господарстві приблизно 120 людей.
Коливається залежно від сезону робіт.
Ми збуваємо його [рис] на внутрішньому ринку.
Україна ще вісім років [тому] забезпечувала
сама себе рисом приблизно на 40%.
Зараз — приблизно на 55%.
Тобто ринок ще досить незаповнений.
Середньостатистично 2,5-2,7 кілограми [рису] їсть українець.
А китаєць — 130 кг.
Всього в Україні минулого року було 12 700 гектарів рису.
Ну а цього [року], я думаю, що буде більше.
Тут ми проводимо гібридізацію,
тобто схрещування батьківських форм рису.
Це лізиметри, cюди садять рис і наповнюють водою.
Там є дно, тобто вода звідти нікуди не дівається.
І рис росте, ну, як ви знаєте, він у воді росте.
Відра – це так...
Відра виглядають відрами,
а називаються вони «вегетаційні посудини».
Це для того нам потрібно,
щоб батьківські форми,
які зацвітають неодночасно,
цвіли все-таки одночасно.
Ми в такий спосіб одну форму висаджуємо раніше за іншу
і досягаємо ефекту, що в нас вони
цвітуть практично в один день.
Це культура, яка походить з південно-східної Азії.
Вся складність селекції — це було перетворити
модель цього рису, який росте в них,
привести до наших умов.
Тобто скоротити вегетаційний період,
зробити його більш холодостійким,
більш пристосованим до наших умов.
Оце була проблема.
Зараз вона частково вирішена.
Спроби були, мабуть, десь на початку 1940-х років.
Це була дельта [Південного] Бугу та Інгульця.
Були фотографії, коли 1941 року,
жінки, я не знаю, скільки їх [було], дуже багато,
і вони сапками проводять воду,
рис росте.
Далі таке велике розповсюдження рис отримав,
коли побудували Краснознам'янську
[зрошувальну] систему.
Завдяки Краснознам'янській системі оці всі пустоші
(тут цічого не було, тут нічого не росло —
солончаки, солонці тощо),
оце все було окультурено.
Вкладено великі кошти,
великі трудові затрати
і побудовано оці рисові системи,
яких зараз загалом в Україні більше не будують.
Тому що це дуже затратна технологія.
Зараз ми працюємо в напрямку,
щоб поширювати наше рисівництво.
Ми втратили Крим, а там, на жаль, половина
наших зрошувальних рисових систем залишилась.
Щоб компенсувати ці втрати,
ми працюємо над поширенням технології
на крапельному зрошуванні.
Ну, певні успіхи є,
але лише три роки в нас ця практика ведеться.
Ну це, по-перше, дуже складна робота, важка.
Це технічно важко виконувати.
Це — вода, це — чоботи, і все літо — там.
Тут повинно бути працелюбство,
впертість водночас.
Ну це, мабуть, найважливіше.
А щоб успішно це було,
то ще треба знати і його [рису] біологію:
як він себе поводить,
як він реагує на те чи інше,
ту чи іншу зміну якихось факторів тощо.
Відновлюється, відновлюється.
Поширюється, особливо в Голопристанському районі.
Там були рисові системи,
зараз вони відновлюються.
Є звідти й замовлення,
є люди, які приїжджають,
хочуть чогось навчитися і пробувати.
Ми зараз впроваджуємо новітні методи,
будуємо біотехнологічну лабораторію.
Що з цього вийде — майбутнє покаже.
Але будемо працювати і на генетичному рівні.
Селекція — безперервний процес.
Він ніколи не закінчиться,
доки людина буде це робити, не робот.
І загалом мета одна — це створити сорт,
такий, щоб просто «без слів».
Всі брали, сіяли і були раді.